انا اللي جايه هنا
لان انا مرتاحه هنا بس وبعدت عن كل حاجه
سببت لي اذى نفسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كتير بتقول ان انا بدار ايتام انا يا
جماعه مش في دار ايتام
[موسيقى]
ى
ان انا مش قادره يعني انا مش قادره افضل
قاعده في نفس المكان اللي اتعرضت فيه
للظلم وللحادثه وللتخلى عني ولكل حاجه انا
مش قادره افضل في نفس المنطقه للاسف
[موسيقى]
يوميا بقيت بصوت بصرخ يعني يوميا نفسيتي
بجد تعبت جدا حتى لما كنت باجي اروح عند
الدكاتره وعدي على نفس المكان بتاع حسيتي
كنت بلاقي نفسي تلقائي بقعد اصرخ واقعد
اقول الحقوا عايزين يموتوني
والموضوع كانه عمل معي زي فوبيا
[موسيقى]
طعمه وطنط قاعده هنا بكامل ارادتي انا مش
قاعده في دار ايتام انا هنا بنزل وبترفض
وبخرج وبروح جلساتي وكل حاجه تمام لو
دارها ايتام مش عايش طبعا كل ده وحتى
بشارك معكم مع الانستغرام على طول الستوري
بتاعتي ان انا خارجه مع صحابي وكده